element 113 is the only one that I've
discussed with an ambassador in fact
it's the only one I've discussed with
two ambassadors because I've discussed
it with both the old and the new
Japanese ambassador to London and the
reason why I was discussing it is
because element 113 is the first element
to be definitely synthesized in Japan
and so it is a huge excitement in the
country I was in Tokyo in February this
year 2016 and I met a representative of
RIKEN the lab where these elements were
synthesized and they gave me a press
release about the element the really
exciting thing from their point of view
is that they get to choose the name of
this element now you have to understand
that making these so-called super-heavy
elements is not a quick process it's not
like boiling things up in a testable and
finding a new element it takes years and
years and years and over the history of
the search for elements the last 200
years there have been hundreds of claims
by people believing that they have
discovered new elements so now the
process is extremely rigorous and now
they've got to the final stage and the
name has been chosen the name they chose
was Nihon ium which is a latinized
version of the Japanese name for Japan
Nihon am sure I pronounced that
incorrectly the experiments that led to
this discovery began a long time ago
more than 12 years ago and like all
elements of this part of the periodic
table they're made by taking a heavy
element in this case bismuth atomic
number 83 and the light element this
case zinc accelerating the zing
to a huge speed and the nuclei fused
together to make an element of 113 what
you have to realize is that you take
billions and billions and perhaps
trillions of zinc atoms to get one atom
of element 113 apparently the Japanese
lab observed three atoms over a period
of nine years so this is not something
that you do quickly on a Friday
afternoon and published the next day a
huge amount of verification is needed to
make sure that what you see is genuine
and the way that you detect these
elements is that once they've formed
they shoot out the back of the bismuth
target onto a detector and then they
decay radioactively into a chain of
different elements and this chain of
elements tells you which elements you've
formed because soon you get to part of
the periodic table where you know how
the elements decay what is amazing
though is that people can also tell a
little bit about the chemistry of these
elements you can only do a limited
amount of chemistry when you have one
atom at a time but what they can do is
to bounce the element the atom when it's
ejected off some sort of surface say
gold or Teflon and see if there is any
difference between the way they stick
you can tell quite a bit about the
element just from this sticking and in
fact their measurements have been made
and element 113 does stick to gold quite
strongly this part of the periodic table
is really unusual because just by chance
the way the atomic numbers add up the
number of the element 113 is the same as
the group it's in at least the 13 is its
in group 13 the same element as boron
and if you go
element 113 dehonian is just below
valium and we know quite a lot about the
chemistry of talion particularly it's
very poisonous now you can't tell
whether neoneun will be poisonous
because you only have one atom even if
you could get one atom inside somebody
it would not poison them chemically
though it's radioactive decay could
cause damage one of the things that's
really interesting about thallium is
that it has three electrons in its outer
shell and in its chemistry it can lose
either one of these to make thallium
plus salts or it can lose all three and
I suspect that in the chemistry of
element 113 the plus 1 state would be
even more prominent than in the
chemistry of thallium because if you go
up the periodic table in the same group
to aluminium you don't get aluminium
plus at all Nihon ium is in the same
group so it has three outer electrons in
just the same way as thallium assuming
that the electrons are arranged in the
same configuration because when you get
to these large atoms their energy levels
of the different shells are very close
together so it would be possible in
least in theory for the configuration to
be different but people assume that it
will be three electrons arranged in the
same way as in boron but much larger
shell
the difficulty is that as the atoms get
bigger and if you imagine the electron
like a particle there you have to go
round and round in the shell and the
speeds they're going round approach the
speed of light and therefore their mass
changes and you get so-called
relativistic effects we made the video
about this on the properties of mercury
which is a much lighter element than
elemental in 13 so people will have to
do quite a lot of calculations and in
the end
unfortunately these will just be theory
because it would be very difficult to
verify them now the important question
that people always ask is
what in earth is the point of making
elements like this and the answer is
that it gives us a much better
understanding of how the protons and the
neutrons in the nucleus bind together
and it's only when you look at the
extremes when they are binding together
relatively weakly that you can test
whether your theories are any good so
although it's an enormous ly expensive
experiment the results are really very
useful professor Joe we've not already
know enough about how protons and
neutrons work I mean we can make atom
bombs and nuclear energy we understand
the everyday elements very well why do
we need to know more have we not we're
not sort of got our head around enough
the radium nucleus threw up an alpha
particle consisting of two protons and
two neutrons the importance of these
experiments is that there have been
predictions that when you get very heavy
elements the so called super-heavy
elements they may become more stable
than one might expect in general what
has been found as people have gone up to
height heavier and heavier nuclei
they've become less and less stable but
now there is some indication that these
very heavy elements are more stable than
one might expect that doesn't mean
they're very stable they may only last a
small fraction of a second but that's
longer than people might have expected
just by extrapolating the lifetimes of
the other ones I think it's a great
honor to anybody to any country and I
think it is a very nice example of
collaboration between different
countries because although it was
discovered in Japan its existence was
verified and justified by experiments in
Germany and Russia so it's a very good
example of international collaboration I
find the name slightly difficult to
pronounce but it's a lot better than
Aeryn to Guinean which I find almost
impossible to pronounce this is the
press release and on the back is a photo
of the leader of the team professor
Morita with presumably the periodic
table showing
his element but the thing I really like
is the quotation at the end it says for
Morita then part of the coming year will
be devoted to thinking of and proposing
a formal name they've now done that but
he's looking forward to the next step in
his research we plan now to look to the
uncharted territory of element 119 and
beyond aiming to examine the chemical
properties of the elements in the 7th
and 8th row of the periodic table and
Sunday to discover the island of
stability so all being well there'll be
lots more periodic videos on the subject
oh I'm wearing a Japanese happy which
was given to me in Tokyo by a great fan
Naga yes or now WA and you can see
unfortunately element 113 comes here in
my armpit
it's a really nice periodic table and
it's even better
on the back walk along and see where the
ants cope
[Music]
by the time we get to here the ions
already traveling at five percent of the
speed of light hits the targets here and
Seville portaits is about 1,000 500
shion's per minute